this was a bad morning here at today and
at NBC News Today Show host Matt Lauer
fired by NBC following a sexual
misconduct investigation we are
heartbroken the news was announced on
The Today Show Wednesday by Savannah
Guthrie and Hoda Kotb I'm heartbroken
from Matt and I'm heartbroken for the
brave colleague who came forward to tell
her story and any other women who have
their own stories to tell the 59 year
olds colleagues from across Morning News
also weighed in Savannah
you know she applauded her colleague
very brave of a colleague I mean Matt
Lauer is an institution there and for
this brand colleague to come forward
with these allegations asserting that
just this week this one does hit close
to home I too have known that for a long
time and he has been a friend and kind
and supportive to me in my transition to
NBC News and I see the anguish on my
colleagues faces Gayle King also
addressed the news just days after her
co-host
Charlie Rose was terminated from CBS
this morning amid sexual harassment
allegations I have a sickening feeling
of deja vu
certainly because we're dealing with our
own situation here but it does send the
message and shows that you are not too
big to fall
[Music]
you
[Music]